They said that the square root of a negative number belonged outside of the
portion of diagram that contains the real numbers. So in this area over here.
And since we don't have a name for the type of numbers right now, we need to
come up with one. And since these numbers are real numbers. You might as well
call these numbers imaginary numbers, since they're not real. I think this is a
pretty cool term. It's hard to even think about what the number that's imaginary
means, or what it really is. We'll get a handle on this soon enough. For now
though, let's talk about the simplest imaginary number we have. Well in my mind
the simplest negative number I can think of is negative 1. The number related to
this that we're interested in then, is the square root of negative 1. Now
because this is the simplest of that new type of numbers that we're talking
about; the imaginary numbers, it gets a special name. It gets its own letter, i,
because it's the simplest imaginary number. Note that even though this is a
letter representing a number, this is not a variable. It's a constant. Just like
we have numbers like pi and e that also have letters going along with, with
them. I is just representing the constant, the square root of -1.. So let's play
around with I a little bit. Since we know that i is just a number, albeit, a new
kind of number, but still just a number. We should be able to take it to
different powers. For each of these, I'd like you to write in what number you
think it's equal to. So what is i to the 0, what is i to the 1, what is i to the
2, etc. Now of course, since I is an imaginary number, we would assume that some
of these answers at least, will be imaginary numbers as well. So I itself will
probably appear somewhere in here. Remember though, that because this is just
another number exponents work with it in exactly the same way. I to the five is
just equal to I times itself five. Times. Or 5 i's multiplied together. I think
you might see something interesting happen when you do these. Also 1 last note.
If you ever feel tempted to write the square root of 1, just write i instead.